Marian tenía la esperanza de convertirse
médica su padre siempre había alentado
sus estudios Pero todo cambió cuando los
talibanes volvieron al poder
nunca había pensado que llegaría un día
en el que no podríamos estudiar más en
el que no podríamos alcanzar nuestros
sueños en lugar de estudiar ahora lavo
los platos lavo la ropa y friego el
suelo todo esto es muy duro
con su salario reducido a casi la mitad
bajo el régimen talibán el padre de
Marian sintió que no podía rechazar a
los posibles pretendientes de sus hijas
cada vez que venían decían que yo no le
daría la mano a mis hijas mi intención
era que terminaran la universidad
después de marzo cuando no se permitió a
las niñas ir a la escuela vi que los
talibanes no iban a dar Un paso atrás
después de eso cuando llegó la propuesta
le dije a mariam que mi experiencia
anterior con los talibanes me dice que
no van a dar marcha atrás
una mezcla de crisis económica y valores
patriarcales muy ubicados hace que las
jóvenes de Afganistán compartan el
destino de Mariano cuando los talibanes
retomaron el control el año pasado hubo
una breve esperanza de que permitirían
más libertades a las mujeres en
comparación con su gobierno de la década
de 1990 pero la reapertura prevista de
las escuelas secundarias para niñas en
marzo fue cancelada y las restricciones
a las mujeres se ha multiplicado la
economía afgana dependiente de la ayuda
también se ha hundido desde la toma del
poder dejando a la mitad de sus 38
millones de habitantes con hambre las
hermanas Sara y Fátima se quedaron sin
poder graduarse de la escuela secundaria
y presentarse a los exámenes de acceso a
la universidad después de que su padre
el sostén de la familia muriera de Kobe
19 decidieron que había que empezar a
buscar marido estamos obligadas a
casarnos porque es mejor casarse que ser
una carga para nuestra familia habíamos
planeado continuar con nuestros estudios
Pero ahora no hay esperanza de continuar
con nuestra educación los expertos dicen
que la educación no solo es fundamental
para retrasar el matrimonio de las niñas
sino también la maternidad que conlleva
una mayor tasa de mortalidad infantil y
maternidad a una edad temprana